would that be justice or would it be its
opposite jerome corsi would know
firsthand and he joins us tonight mr.
Corsi thank you very much for coming on
my pleasure Tucker thanks so before then
you're not under oath and so our viewers
will have to assess the accuracy of what
you say but before we get to your
interaction with the Muller
investigation just the basics have you
ever had contact with Julian Assange no
I I've never met Julian Assange I've
never spoken with him I've never emailed
him I've had no contact with Julian
Assange whatsoever have you ever had
contact with Russian intelligence or
subverted knowingly subverted the
interests of your own country absolutely
not I've been a loyal American I have no
contacts with Russian intelligence I
have no business interests in Russia I
have nothing to do with Russia I've
never been to Russia so tell me if I
summarized what happened to you
accurately the special counsel's office
gets ahold of your personal computer and
your phone they've got all the records
all the data and they start asking you
about things they already know and they
ask you have you ever tried to broker a
meeting with Assange
you don't remember forwarding this email
they come back and say bingo you just
committed a felony is that what would
happen it's even worse first of all I
offered I gave my computers as special
counsel I gave them my cell phone I gave
them all my email accounts I gave them
everything they wanted my Twitter
accounts my I signed permission and
handed all this over now the first day
when I was interviewed I didn't remember
that email now the special counsel came
in and blew up and they actually sent me
home and gave me an opportunity to
review the emails when I came back I
amended the testimony to say that I now
remember the email as special counsel
was happy with that until I couldn't
give them what they wanted which was a
connection that I had with Assange that
they assumed I had which I didn't have
now suddenly they forgot they allowed me
to amend my testimony and they're going
back to the mistake I made
they won when I forgot the email so it's
really
I think completely fraudulent the charge
that they were trying to get me to plead
to and I refuse to plead to a lot so I
bet I'm a little confused here so they
have is there anything that you would
held for them you say you pay them
access to everything with your
communication so if you'd had direct
contact with Julian Assange or with
someone else who had had contact with
the son they would already know that
wouldn't they I would think so I mean I
gave them everything voluntarily I have
a time machine on that computer which
recorded everything precisely and kept
it in the time machine back through 2015
I hate the computer broke in 2018 but I
gave that I kept it they had I
voluntarily gave them the 17-inch Apple
laptop and the time machine I gave them
my cell phone I signed over permission
for all of my emails gave them the
usernames and passwords I allowed them
to see my Twitter I even helped Quantico
download my Twitter and my Google
accounts I signed over Verizon accounts
everything they wanted
I had nothing to hide I gave them to him
immediately and for having forgotten on
day one because I hadn't reviewed the
emails this particular email about Ted
Malik I'm now being charged with
willfully and knowingly giving false
information which is which is nonsense
I never willingly and falsely gave false
information I intended always to tell
the truth my memory was not perfect
right so let me just say that if you
deleted emails presumably the special
counsel would have the ability to
retrieve those emails so they would know
I think what your communications were
I've read accounts in the press I read
one in the Washington Monthly a liberal
magazine saying that you deserve to go
to prison because you've expressed views
that they don't like do you think that
your political views are playing a role
in the decision of the Special Counsel
to charge you with a felony yes I think
and also by the way they accused me of
deleting emails and I told them to
restore they restored the emails I
supposedly deleted through the time
machine this is a political win chud
because I did not have a contact with
Assange but you
had figured out that Assange had
Podesta's emails I figured it out and
told Roger stolen and told many people
in August and it just happened that I
was right well the prosecutor said dr.
Corsi we're not going to believe that on
your 25th wedding anniversary day to
Italy with your wife and family
you had divine inspiration and God told
you Podesta had a song his emails why I
said I don't know what we're going to
put it that Kressley but I did figure it
out and I connect the dots and this time
I happen to you're right you just won't
believe that I figured it out so so
quickly because I can't resist asking
because I think the human cost is worth
knowing about what does this cost you oh
it's a it's going to be it just to get
started a couple hundred thousand
dollars I mean it bankrupts you're very
quickly and and the special prosecutors
blow you up they do this what I call
perjury trap it's really you know they
ask you a question they have material
they won't show you you've forgotten
about it they say you just lied because
this email you forgot about 2016 proves
your current memory is wrong I mean it's
a memory test it's just it doesn't
accuse you of lying it's completely
rigged and it's politically driven by
Clinton operatives who have an agenda
and if you can't give them Rogers right
if you can't give them what they're
looking for to fill their narrative they
blow you up and charge you with a crime
I think the public should see what's
happening and so I'm grateful that you
came on to explain it Thank You Jerome
Corsi thank you